IT.
ALAN DERSHOWITZ, THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: WHEN THE FAKE DUCHESS
FROM LOS ANGELES AND HER DEAD
HUSBAND TOLD OPRAH THAT THE
ROYAL FAMILY IS RACIST.
HUH?
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
FOR DOING THAT, THE MEDIA SAID
PIERS MORGAN WAS RACISM.
WHEN SHARON OSBORNE TRIED TO
DEFEND HIM, THE MEDIA ACCUSED
HER OF RACISM TOO, THAT SHE WAS
A BIGOT FOR ASKING HOW IS PIERS
MORGAN A RACIST, POINTING OUT
THAT THE FAKE DUCHESS IS LYING.
IN A SHOW, SHE EXPLAINS HOW SHE
FOUGHT THE URGE TO WAG A MIDDLE
FINGER IN THE FACE OF HER CBS
COHOSTS.
WATCH.
>> IT WAS SLAUGHTERED THAT
MORNING, AND CBS DENIED
RESPONSIBILITY ON THE NEWS, AND
THAT'S 'CAUSE THEY'RE WANKERS.
>> WE REACHED OUT TO CBS FOR
COMMENT ON WHAT SHARON HAD TO
SAY, AND THEY REITERATED THEIR
STATEMENT FROM MARCH, FINDING NO
EVIDENCE SHE HAD BEEN SET.
>> HOW DOES THIS MAKE SENSE?
YOU CAN GET GANGED UP ON LIVE
TELEVISION?
WHEN YOU GO TO DEFEND YOURSELF
AGAINST ACCUSATIONS, YOU GET
FIRED FOR CREATING A HOSTILE
WORK ENVIRONMENT.
THIS IS THE WORLD WE LIVE IN
TODAY.
>> I WANTED TO LOOK INTO THE
CAMERA AND SAY [BLEEP] AND CBS
TAKE THAT.
>> Tucker: SHARON OSBORNE JOINS
US TONIGHT.
SHARON, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
COMING ON.
WHEN HISTORIANS GO BACK, DO A
POSTMORTEM ON OUR SOCIETY, HOW
DID EVERYONE GOING CRAZY IN A
FOUR-YEAR PERIOD, WHAT HAPPENED
TO YOU IS ONE OF THE NET YOU SAY
THINGS I'VE EVER SEEN, SIX
DEGREES AWAY FROM SEPARATION,
YOU SPOKE UP FOR AN OLD FRIEND,
AND HAD TO LEAVE YOUR JOB.
YOU'VE THOUGHT ABOUT THIS A LOT
SINCE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF IT?
>> UMM, IT IS THE WORLD THAT
WE'RE LIVING IN, ESPECIALLY IN
FILM AND TV, WHERE PEOPLE WANT
TO BE OVERLY, OVERLY WOKE.
SO THE SLIGHTEST THING, IT'S
LIKE WALKING ON EGGSHELLS.
AND THERE ARE NO SECOND CHANCES.
YOU COULD -- YOU KNOW, IN
TODAY'S WORLD, YOU COULD HAVE
PUT SOMETHING ON YOUR SOCIAL
MEDIA 10-12 YEARS AGO, AND
PEOPLE WILL LOOK BACK AND THEY
WILL FIRE YOU BECAUSE YOU WROTE
IT 10-12 YEARS AGO.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S DIFFERENT
SCENARIOS.
SOMEBODY COULD HAVE BEEN DRUNK
WITH A BUNCH OF PEOPLE, YOU
KNOW, OUT OF CONTROL, SO YOU MAY
HAVE CHANGED YOUR MIND BY NOW.
BUT NO.
EVEN FROM YEARS AGO, PEOPLE WANT
TO CONDEMN YOU.
>> Tucker: I ALWAYS WONDERED
WATCHING THIS STORY, I NEVER
ASKED YOU ABOUT IT, BUT A LOT OF
THE PEOPLE YOU WORKED WITH, WHO
I THINK YOU GOT ALONG WITH
PERFECTLY WELL, REALLY BEHAVED
IN A DESPICABLE WAY TOWARD YOU,
IN A COWARDLY CRUEL WAY, AND I
WONDER WHAT WAS YOUR
CONVERSATION OFF CAMERA WITH
THEM LIKE?
DID THEY EVER APOLOGIZE TO YOU
FOR TREATING YOU LIKE THAT?
>> NO.
I HAD TO APOLOGIZE TO THEM.
I MEAN, I MUST TRUTHFUL THAT IN
THE FIRST BREAK I WAS SAYING TO
ONE OF MY COAST HOSTS, TALK TO
ME, TALK TO ME, TELL ME WHY
YOU'RE DOING THIS, TELL ME WHERE
THIS CAME FROM, WHY ARE YOU
DOING THIS?
SHE TURNED HER BACK ON ME LIKE
THIS AND PRETENDED TO BE TALKING
TO THE PERSON IN THE BOOTH AND
WOULDN'T TALK TO ME.
SO I SWORE AT HER.
I DID DO THAT.
I SWEAR A LOT AT MY FRIENDS.
IF SOMEONE IS A REAL FRIEND, WE
WORKED TOGETHER 11 YEARS,
TRAVELED TOGETHER, DONE
EVERYTHING TOGETHER, BEEN TO MY
HOUSE LOTS OF TIMES, YOU KNOW,
SUPPOSED TO HAVE LOVED MY
FAMILY, TOO, AND THEN SHE TURNS
AROUND AND STABS ME IN THE BACK.
YOU KNOW, I DO SWEAR A LOT.
AND THAT'S WHO I AM.
CBS KNEW THAT BEFORE THEY GAVE
ME THE JOB.
I WAS THERE NEARLY 11 YEARS.
SO 11 YEARS OF ME SWEARING
DIDN'T BOTHER THEM OFF AIR.
>> Tucker: IT'S ONE OF THE
CRUELEST MOST AWFUL THINGS I'VE
SEEN.
IT'S A SMALL THING, BUT IT TELLS
YOU A LOT ABOUT THE MINDSET.
ANYWAY, I APPRECIATE THE FACT
THAT YOU SURVIVED AND THAT
YOU'RE BACK ON TV AND THAT YOU
JOINED US TONIGHT.
>> WELL, THANK YOU VERY, VERY
MUCH.
THE THING IS IT'S NOT JUST A
SMALL THING, BECAUSE NOBODY WILL
TOUCH ME NOW, BECAUSE OF WHAT
HAPPENED.
SO IT'S NOT A SMALL THING, BUT
I'M FINE.
I CAN TAKE CARE OF MYSELF.
>> Tucker: GOOD.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE PEOPLE THAT
CAN'T?
>> Tucker: WELL, THAT'S RIGHT.
>> THAT'S WHAT WE'VE GOT TO
WORRY ABOUT.
>> Tucker: I COULDN'T AGREE WITH
YOU MORE.
>> THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE THAT LOSE
THEIR JOBS.
THAT'S WHO I WORRY ABOUT.
NOT ME.
>> Tucker: YES, YES.
PEOPLE WITH NO POWER.
SHARON O